I'm pretty solid and saying this is not
a $100 cup of coffee if they charge me a
hundred bucks for this I would have
words many words hello my name is Kelsey
I've been a barista for a little over
three years hi my name is Danny I am a
barista and I've been a barista for
about a year and a half now today we
will see if I can guess which cup of
coffee is a hundred dollars
[Music]
all right I'm blindfolded I'm nervous
I'm ready to try expensive coffee wanna
smell it first
okay smells kind of like a floral I
would say mm-hmm smells like nuts like
in a good way
guys yeah definitely a little earthy
kind of like you get like that floral
taste to it I like this one yeah it's
fine like on a scale of 1 to 10 and like
strength they give it like a 3 but it
has a lovely bitter aftertaste I'm not I
don't hate it I would say this is more
like a pour-over kind of coffee like one
of the cheaper side ones I don't think
it's the hundred dollar coffee I'm
pretty solid and saying this is not a
100 dollar cup of coffee if they charge
me a hundred bucks for this I would have
words many words I don't know if I'm
spacing the right way words someone's
getting words this one's already
stronger and smell smells like kinda
like a perfume in a way like you feel
fancy already kind ringing this
[Music]
okay yeah that's definitely fancy it
tastes a little more like a blonde it's
got more citrus to it yeah I don't love
a citrus in a coffee I'm a purist I like
a bean to be a bean you know what I mean
it has like a good mix of like bitter
and sweetness um an acidity - I like
this one a lot I think this definitely
could be a contender for the hundred
dollar I don't know it takes a little
more expensive than the last one
but I'm pretty sure it's not a 100
dollar cup of coffee next
[Music]
I can't describe that smell haha hold on
whoa that is a coffee I've never tasted
the flavor of before it's very unique oh
that's good I'm into this a very into
what I was happening right I can't see a
thing does kind of have a little like
earthy taste to it but I don't dislike
it like it's well made I will say that
see it's thicker than the other two the
second one had a higher quality but I
don't love citrus and coffee but I liked
the first one better but this one beats
them both easy I definitely think it's a
contender cuz I mean I've never tried a
hunter on the coffee so it could be
something completely different I don't
know if it's a hundred dollars but of
the three that I've had so far it's
closer on the way to triple-digit
smell it mm-hmm I'm not getting an
aggressive smell but it's definitely
there it's definitely coffee smells kind
of burnt from the beginning hmm yeah
this one is definitely like kind of like
a burnt one like maybe you find like in
like an office wait what is happening in
here I would definitely say that this
one is probably the cheapest one of all
of them not my favorite but I mean some
people do like it oh I like that I like
that a lot guys this might be it this
might be pricey ass coffee I think that
the first three definitely showcased
more higher quality flavor profiles so
for me this is definitely not the
hundred dollar coffee if I had to guess
which one probably this one is the
hunter dollar coffee
[Music]
so my personal favorite was the second
one I would probably range that one to
be around $100 I'm gonna say 4 was the
most expensive is it you're out of the
resource first one is the second most
expensive really the second one is the
cheapest the third one was the most
expensive Wow and the last one was the
third most expensive guide yeah oh I am
shook a little bit that first one is not
the cheapest one but its water sirs and
Madam's it's not good you know I
definitely could have done better I feel
like I did kind of have that intuition
like the third one probably was the one
but I think I just wanted to say that my
favorite was the expensive one I spend
most of my money on rent and coffee
anyway so you know I'd probably I'd
probably drink any of them again if
given a chance just because caffeine is
my friend
[Music]
you